so a couple weeks ago Chris and I went
to San Francisco to shoot some videos
while we were there however we managed
to stumble across a future toilet I had
a great time using the future toilet I
use the future toilet and it was a
nightmare but it's a toilet that has a
bidet built in and also other features
I'm excited
I've never used a future toilet this is
big for me and Keith is infectious
you know his enthusiasm made me go you
know I don't have to poop but I want to
try the future toilet so of course I
pull out my cell phone but now I had to
use the bathroom
I actually really had to use the
bathroom I'm on the toilet doing what a
person does on a toilet and then awesome
I'm done using the bathroom now the fun
begins
there's great like okay I get it
but I want more you know so I up the
pressure a little bit how can you go max
pressure I'm like full blast this is
great this is amazing feel so clean so
Keith probably told a story about how he
warmed it up and tried to like figure
things out I I just sat down and was
ready to go once again I did not have to
poop I guess I just started Oh God oh my
god feel so clingy
oh my god it's so clean I think this is
ghost forever and so it goes like one
cycle it doesn't stop on its own it will
just keep going unless you stop it
something sitting there with just water
shooting up my empty pole not cleaning
anything off of it just like just just
penetrating me with water
now's the ghost part I turn I turn the
day off and I'm like well okay I I guess
I I just got shot in the with some water
I guess I was supposed to be real up
relaxing I huh I guess I have to poop
now but of course I had to poop because
I essentially had a water balloon so I
start pooping and it's just a waterfall
just water just comes out of my butt and
then poop follows it it's not really
diarrhea it's just like poop paste like
and it's everywhere
I feel clean I feel refreshed and I
don't even know what part of me isn't
full of poop anymore
overall for me I had a great time using
the future toilet I felt alone with a
machine oddly slightly aroused and I
don't know if that's a bidet feature but
that's just what was going on I'm like I
gotta go I don't even know what just
happened I feel violated it was a great
experience I think if I had the option I
would use it all the time it's like
traumatizing to me but Keith thinks is
really funny so he set up lights and a
background for us to talk to a camera
about the story and it's really just
about how terrible my experience was I
don't really want this to go on the
internet I don't have like lost track of
what what is and what isn't private
anymore
I work at BuzzFeed